it's been a crazy week in america let's
find out what happened
due to russia's invasion of ukraine
president biden announced this week that
the u.s will target the main artery of
russia's economy because if there's one
thing americans know how to do it's how
to block an artery
[Applause]
a photo that spread on the internet this
week of queen elizabeth ii shaking hands
with canadian prime minister justin
trudeau was reportedly photoshopped
here's the real photo
yes
oh my god i love you so much
he's like this happens to me everywhere
everywhere i go
but bring it in
a team of health experts this week
issued more than 250 recommendations of
steps to take to combat the coronavirus
pandemic it was published in a little
too late magazine
after a long cold winter spring weather
finally came to new york city this week
and you can feel the excitement in the
air because here at the amber ruffin
show springtime begins with one of the
most delightful wonders in all of
creation
the annual wally blossom
now
as you can see
our cue card guy wally has begun to
shake off the winter frost and blossom
into a dazzling display of freshness and
vitality
for just a few days wally's blooms will
fill the air with the sweet fragrance of
renewal rebirth and fresh green cue card
ink
in addition the cue card crop that was
planted during the winter has started to
emerge from the earth and will soon bear
fruit
and while they may seem tiny now those
little sprouts will soon grow into the
large blank cards that provide wally and
his family nourishment throughout the
year
and it wouldn't be the wally blossom
without the annual wally blossom
festival which attracts thousands of
tourists each year it features art
installations a parade and even a 5k
so
do yourself a favor and bring the family
down to the amber ruffin show to catch a
glimpse of one of our nation's most
enduring traditions
gorgeous
beautiful
moving on
a black staten island woman has
collected around 20 000 african-american
historical artifacts in her home that's
crazy said critics about a black woman
living in staten island
i lived in staten island you lived in
staten island yep tarik did they get you
uh
no cause i don't live there anymore oh
okay how bad was it one to ten oh it was
pretty bad that's ten oh wow wow wow
yeah it was pretty bad coming from omaha
yeah that must be pretty bad yeah
outside of wu-tang like there's no
sanity in that place oh
outside of wu-tang wow
there is no sanity in that place wow you
know it's bad when wu-tang is the
measure yeah
on a scale from risotto space yeah
according according to a new study
exposure to leaded gasoline caused
people who were born in the 1960s and
70s to lose about six iq points even
crazier the gasoline was typically found
in these containers
tasted great
the nhl this week unveiled a new logo
for the stanley cup playoffs also this
is smart they're adding a lid to the cup
[Applause]
and that's what i like
[Laughter]
national bee nasty day was this week but
some people celebrate it every day
[Applause]
and finally researchers believe that a
328 million year old fossil that had 10
limbs and two rows of suckers is an
ancestor of the octopus and not as i had
assumed an ancestor of yo mama
and that was the monologue did you guys
like the monologue
good
good
i'm glad you liked it because it was
made with love now cnn reported this
week that the war in ukraine has sent
president biden into the situation room
nearly every day incidentally the
situation room is also what chipotle
calls the bathroom
you know you guys
as much as i think that's a funny joke i
feel like that punch line is well-worn
territory we get it chipotle gives you
diarrhea
you know it's just an easy joke and i'm
ashamed i made it
you know i'm vowing right now to never
make a chipotle joke again
it's a well i go to a lot it's toilet
humor and
i'm starting to feel like it's lazy so i
want to give up jokes about chipotle in
style
[Music]
i'm never gonna joke never ever gonna
joke about chipotle again
it's rude it's grass to talk about
blowing ass i vow to be a better man
no i'm never gonna say
chipotle's motto is food with integrity
but it should be [ __ ] happens
again
that's right i'm growing i'm evolving
and i'm moving past the need to say
things like
whenever i go to chipotle i always ask
for queso as in k so i just [ __ ] myself
good you shouldn't say that and i'll
make double sure not to say
once chipotle had me ruin a toilet so
bad they put it in the
moma i'm never gonna joke never ever
gonna joke about chipotle again
it's rude it's grass to talk about
blowing ass i've had to be a better man
no i'm never
when the cashier asks cash or credit i
say i'm paying with my ass
again
please stop derrick i'm telling you the
things i'm not gonna say anymore i'm not
gonna say this stuff look i'll tell you
the same thing i tell the chipotle
employee every time i go
what's that there's someone in here
look
the truth is i love chipotle every time
i get drunk it's the only thing i want
[ __ ] i could tear up some chipotle right
now and i'm not even drunk
yeah i'm a little buzzed but that's not
what this is about
it's about these jokes being so unfair
so i'm done
this time i swear
no
i'm never
gonna joke about your body baby
it's rude it's grass to talk about
blowing ass i'm about to be a better man
no i'm never gonna say
after i hate chipotle i took a [ __ ] so
bad it's now a texas governor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you